his computer-generated voice has become
familiar to generations of people
instantly garnering recognition as the
words of a genius his name is uttered in
the same breath as Einstein and Galileo
and yet few people can understand the
complexities of his theories what they
do know though is that Stephen Hawking
overcame physical obstacles that would
have defeated many people and he did
that in order to pursue his passions in
the process he became an inspiration to
millions and added greatly to our
understanding of the universe in this
week's by graphics we undertake a brief
history of Stephen Hawking and just
before you get started with the video
today do you want to say that it's
brought to you by the great courses plus
the rate courses classes and on-demand
video learning services got lectures
from top Ivy League professors as well
as experts from other places like the
Smithsonian National Geographic etc it's
like a university education but at your
own pace there are no tests no schedules
and it's incredibly easy to access you
can do it on the PC on tablet on a phone
and you can get a free trial by going to
the great courses plus com forward slash
biographic some more about that a little
later in this video
[Music]
Stephen William Hawking was born at the
height of the Second World War on
January the 8th 1842 in Oxford England
it was exactly 300 years after the death
of the father of astronomy Galileo
Galilei both of his parents were
graduates of Oxford University his
father Frank was a medical researcher
while his mother Isabelle worked as a
medical research secretary they were a
middle-class family with both parents
being thought of in their community as
rather odd brain boxes Stephen began his
schooling at Byron House School in
Highgate the school used a new
progressive method of teaching to which
Stephen did not take he stayed here for
three years though and by the age of
eight he could still not read at the
war's end
Frank was offered a job at the National
Institute of Medical Research and the
family moved to some talents here Frank
wanted his son to attends the
prestigious Westminster School
however Stephen was sick on the day of
the entrance exam and he ended up going
to nearby and Alvin school instead
Stephen at this school he was seen as a
nerdy outcast he was small skinny and he
spoke with a lisp that made it hard to
understand what he was saying for the
first two years of his time there he was
very much a loner in the third year he
managed to find a small group of
like-minded friends there
extracurricular activities included
going on long bike rides and inventing
board games Stephen he proved to be the
most inventive and creative of this
group and would come up with the rules
and organize the state of play in these
games Stephen had two younger sisters
and brother who was adopted in 1955
however his parents showed little
interest in domestic affairs the Hawking
house was filled with books and the
parents were too busy feeding their
minds often reading books during dinner
rather than conversing with their
children Stephen regularly had his
friends over where they would busy
themselves building model planes and
electronic devices from about the age of
12 onwards their discussions extended
from science to religion they debated
the big questions of life among
themselves and it was at this time that
Stephen began forming his atheistic
beliefs Stephens teachers they soon
identified a remarkable talent from
automatics and physics in him he seems
to intuitively know the answers without
having to work through the problem by
the age of 14 he knew that he wanted to
specialize in physics he felt that he
could provide an insight into the big
questions that he and his friends have
been grappling with where we are all
from why we are here and where we're
going
at the age of 17 Stephen felt ready to
take the entrance exam for university
college at Oxford the exam was extremely
challenging consisting of five papers
and a general knowledge exam Hawking
came out with a score of 95 percent once
again though he found himself as an
outsider at this prestigious place of
learning he had no friends and so he
kept to himself
furthermore they found the lectures to
be too basic for him which led to
boredom he stopped going to many of them
and still easily passed his exams
the only lectures that he got any
intellectual challenge from were those
presented by his physics tutor Robert
Berman Hawking was well ahead of his
fellow students despite being much young
of many of them his knowledge was so
advanced that he occasionally made
corrections in the very textbooks that
he was studying at the end of his second
year he easily won the university
physics prize while at Oxford Stephen
took up the sport of rowing rowing was
and still is a very serious business at
Oxford University and Stephen threw
himself into it with complete
commitments he became a coxswain the
person who yells instructions to the
rowers he simply loved the thrill of
guiding his team to success it was his
involvement in the rowing team which
allowed Stephens a break out of his
isolation and develop some budding
friendships by the time that his old
school mates from since albuns turned up
as freshmen they were surprised to
discover that the awkward boy that they
knew had become a confident young man
who had found a comfortable niche for
himself at Oxford in fact he became so
immersed in the social life of his
environments that despite his innate
ability he began to fall back
academically with his third year exams
approaching he quickly realized that he
was not fully prepared he decided that
his best bet was to focus solely on the
theoretical problems that he could solve
using his innate skill the results of
the exam had him teetering between a
first and second class honours degree he
needed it to be first class in order to
gain admittance to Cambridge where he
planned to begin his work on his PhD the
result depended on a final oral exam
which she aced gaining first class
honors before heading off to Cambridge
Hawking took a trip to Iran with a
friend he began at Cambridge in October
of 1962 while he had been expecting to
directly under the guidance of the
famous astronomer Fred how this was
actually not to be the case he was
disappointed to find out that his tuner
was actually Dennis schema the reality
of the situation was though the Hawking
was actually better off on the skier man
who had more time to guide his students
than Hoyle would have had Hawking
specialized in the study of cosmology it
was now that he faced his first real
intellectual challenge he quickly
realized that his mathematical knowledge
was not deep enough for him to really
get to grips with the complications of
Einstein's general theory of relativity
[Music]
at about this time hawking began to
experience some physical abnormalities
his speech was starting to slur and he
was prone to losing his balance when he
returns home for the 1962 Christmas
holidays his parents were so concerned
that they sent him to a specialist a
series of tests were undertaken and then
it was simply a matter of waiting for
the results
in the meantime Hawking attended a New
Year's Eve party where he met a young
lady by the name of Jane Wilde Jane was
attracted to the eccentric young
intellectual and the two struck up an
immediate attraction Stephen had already
returned to Cambridge when the results
of the tests came through he had
developed ALS which is also known as Lou
Gehrig's disease
it's a condition in which the body's
cells to generate causing paralysis and
muscle atrophy yes while the body
deteriorates the brain is unaffected so
walking now at the prospect of being
trapped within a dysfunctional body the
prognosis related to Hawking was that he
had just two years to live the symptoms
that he experienced in the first few
months were weakness stammering while
speaking and having trouble swallowing
Hawking later reflected on his feelings
at the time a disease which can never be
healed I'm in the clutches of the
disease which is calling me closer to my
death the thought itself used to bring
cramps of fear in the stomach why have I
only been caught by just disease Stevens
doctors and his parents advised him to
continue his studies at Cambridge they
believed that staying focused on the
goal of achieving his PhD would help him
to cope with the pain and frustration of
dealing with his failing body but
Hawking struggled with the idea that he
was working so hard for a reward that he
would probably not live to receive what
was the point is the question that kept
dancing around in the back of his brain
it has been reported the Hawking fell
into a deep depression at this time he
was spending his days drinking and
listening to Wagner in a student flats
however the man himself actually later
denied this assertion he certainly went
into a period of confusion and lack of
focus but he also did his best to
continue with the studies after a year
his symptoms had stabilized and his
spirits began to pick up it was also
this time that he picked up his real
with Jane walls he became a great
supporter and encouraged her of him it
was she who gave him a glimmer of hope
for a brighter future the two became
engaged in October of 1964 Jane had
committed herself to looking after
Steven for the rest of his life and they
were married on July the 14th 1965 after
two years of living with the disease
Hawking was able to get around on a cane
though this speech was becoming
increasingly unintelligible he was still
searching for an area of focus for his
thesis Fred Hoyle has just pronounced
his theories on the discovery of the
universe and Hawking believed that
Boyle's theory was flawed and he
publicly challenged these theories he
then proceeded to write his thesis on
the topic and it was well received by
the cosmology community it was this that
really established talking as a player
of note in the field
[Music]
after graduating from Cambridge with a
PhD in Applied Mathematics and
theoretical physics hawking applied form
and received a fellowship at Cambridge
is gone villain Keyes College this
provided him with a secure job which
gave him further confidence in his
future yes his condition had now reached
the stage where he could no longer write
so he had to rely on Jane to record his
thoughts Hawking's job at the college
required him to supervise students for a
few hours every day providing him with
plenty of time to pursue his research
studies he and Jane set up their home in
a small house not far from the college
they enjoyed entertaining friends and
the house was often filled with dinner
guests in December of 1965 Hawking was
invited to the United States to give an
address at a Miami conference however
his speech was so slurred that a friend
had to read the address on his behalf
the speech though it was well received
further cementing his growing reputation
as an exciting new thinker in the world
of cosmology Marjane spends a lot of
time and effort caring for her husband
she had given up on her own career when
the couple had met she was in the midst
of a degree in Modern Languages she
completed that degree in 1967 that year
she also gave birth to their first child
Robert two more children would follow
Lucy in 1970 and Timothy in 1979 the
birth of his first child was a further
motivator for Hawking to positively
toward the future despite the fact that
it already outlived his initial
prognosis he had a family now along with
a promising career as a budding genius
in fact some were even already calling
him the successor to Einstein
the turning points in Hawking's career
occurred when he attended a lecture by
mathematician Robert Penrose in the
address
Penrose expounded his theory of
space-time singularity in the center of
a black hole
Hawking latched on to the pan or a
singularity theory and applied it to the
entire universe if he could prove the
mathematics behind it he knew that this
would be a momentous addition to the
understanding of the origins of the
universe mathematics was Hawking strong
points so he collaborated with Penrose
who presented his calculations by way of
visual representations in order to help
Hawking who was unable to record the
calculations himself the Big Bang Theory
was predicated on the idea that the
universe was not static but actually
continually expanding according to this
theory the universe began as a black
hole that was held together by gravity
the egg at the center of the hole it was
extremely hot and as it cooled over
billions of years it started to expand
with the protons neutrons and electrons
forming the Stars and the galaxies which
make up our visible universe
Hawking he was not the originator of
this new theory but his work such as the
sa singularities and the geometry of
space-time gave it a strong underpinning
[Music]
by the end of the 1960's Hawking's ALS
had deteriorated to the point where he
had become wheelchair-bound
the intense speed of his mental
cognition however caused him to move
around with maximum speed in this
wheelchair it also caused him to quickly
become impatient and irritable with
those around him despite his raw
temperament seem actually became very
popular with students and colleagues
alike in the early 1970s Hawking took on
the task of reconciling the two opposing
theories that had divided physics for
years quantum mechanics and relativity
during his work he discovered that black
holes in it radiation he published this
finding in an article in nature magazine
there was initially some push back to
this but eventually his finding was
accepted and it came to be known as
Hawking radiation the discovery of black
hole radiation was a big deal and it led
to publicity beyond the scientific
community Hawking was now receiving
general media attention giving rise to
the fame which would see him lauded as
the wheelchair genius in 1973 Hawking
published his first book the large-scale
structure of space-time the following
year at 32 he became one of the youngest
people to become a member of the Royal
Society in 1974 he was also invited to
spend the year at the California
Institute of Technology yeah he was able
to make use of the very best equipment
including the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
that is attached to the Institute during
his year in America he was able to work
alongside famous American theoretical
physicists kept Thorne the Hawking
family thoroughly enjoyed their year in
sunny California over the years Stephen
would frequently return to Caltech to
make use of their advanced facilities at
the end of their time in the US the
family returned to Cambridge where they
moved into a bigger house on the college
grounds in 1976 as students in residence
by the name of Don Paige joined the
Hawking household page you would walk
walking to this office every morning and
perform other caretaking jobs around
this time Jane began to feel confined by
her life as a mother and wife to a
wheelchair-bound husband with Paige now
on hand to help out with Stevens care
she embarked upon a PhD in
evil Spanish poetry once she gained it
she began teaching at Cambridge
University the couple began experiencing
marital problems from the mid-1970s one
cause of their dis court was the wildly
divergent religious views that each held
Jane was a committed Christian while
Stephen he was a confirmed atheist the
relationship remained strained until
their divorce in 1995 in 1976 Hawking
was invited to a number of conferences
around the United States following which
he ended up on TV talk shows though his
speech was difficult to understand he
did prove hit with American audiences in
1979 Hawking was appointed Lucasian
Professor of mathematics at Cambridge
this position brought great prestige
with the couple now being the center of
the Cambridge social elite Hawking
enjoyed attending concerts and movies
and despite his physical limitations he
was enjoying his life more than ever
before still he became disappointed at
the lack of facilities for handicapped
people in the community and became an
advocate for disabled facilities in 1983
a BBC horizon documentary gave TV
viewers an insight into the private life
of the wheelchair genius this went a
long way in promoting his celebrity
status in 1984 he put out several
feelers to publishing houses to write a
definitive book of his theories for a
lay audience Bantam publishing offered
him a 250 thousand dollar advance it
took four years do you produce the book
which he called a brief history of time
it became an instant bestseller and to
date has sold more than 10 million
copies in July of 1985 Hawking was in
Geneva when he found himself unable to
breathe after arriving in the hospital
he underwent tracheotomy surgery the
surgery it was a success but the payoff
was that he lost his voice the challenge
was now how to provide Hawking with a
way to communicate with the world and
this was solved by a computer programmer
by the name of Walt Walters his
equaliser program allowed Hawking to
select words from a screen that would
then be converted into a voice
synthesizer
from the early 1980s onwards Hawking and
employed full-time nurses by the end of
the decade he had become alarmingly
close to one of them a woman by the name
of Alain Mason she was a woman with a
dominance and protective personality in
early 1990 Hawking told Jane that he was
leaving the family home and moving in
with Elaine
Mason was herself married to a family
friend at that time Hawking instituted
divorce proceedings to officially end
his marriage to Jane when the divorce
came through in 1995 he and Elaine were
married in the ensuing years there were
rumors that Elaine was physically
controlling and abusive to her husbands
after eleven years the marriage ended in
his autobiography Hawking referred to
his years with Elaine as passionate and
tempestuous in the 1990s Hawking became
interested in time-travel he was of the
opinion that the only possible way for
time-travel to exist would be if it did
not alter the status quo in other words
if a time-travel machine could be
created in the future people would only
be able to travel back until the time
when that machine was created because
prior to that time the machine did not
exist many people they rejected
Hawking's ideas on time-travel and in
order to prove his point in an
irreverent
way he decided to hold a party which was
open to anyone and served free food and
champagne the catch was that he only
advertised the events after it had
occurred so only time travelers would be
aware of it
unsurprisingly though no one turned up
in the early 2000s Hawking focused on
publishing more popular books starting
with 2000 and ones that universe in a
nutshell and in 2005 he put out a brief
history of time both of which were
bestsellers by then his iconic status
was well established being cemented with
appearances on The Simpsons and Star
Trek The Next Generation
by 2005 Hawking's condition had
deteriorated to the extent that he could
only control his speech controls with
movements of his cheek muscles from 2009
he could no longer move his electric
wheelchair himself and his breathing
became increasingly difficult the end
game peacefully on the morning of March
the 14th 2018 it was the one hundred and
thirty ninth anniversary of the birth of
Albert Einstein Stephen Hawking was a
professor at one of the best
universities in the world since he was a
man who shared his knowledge with the
world through books that could be
understood by everyday folks and that's
why I'm particularly pleased that the
great courses plus is involved with
today's video on their learning platform
you can learn from Ivy League professors
and others as they give lectures online
these can be a great way to learn about
some of the concepts that Hawking works
on including lectures about black holes
and quantum physics but there's also
plenty of other stuff on there from
history to travel to health basically
it's really a university education but
it's at your own pace with no tests and
no schedules and it's also very easy to
access you can do it on your PC on your
tablet even on your phone
they've even recently added streaming so
you can listen on the move something I
particularly love I just pop the audio
in when I'm walking around or going for
a jog and on the platform there are
currently 10,000 lectures then you can
choose from so yeah it's all great stuff
and the best way to find that out is to
try it for yourself and you can do that
for free by going to you the great
courses plus comm forward slash
biographic s' or simply clicking the
link in the description below and doing
that does help support this show getting
more biographic out to you every week so
again the great courses plus it's just a
great way to expand your knowledge on a
whole range of subjects taught by the
best in the world and as always I really
hope you enjoyed that video please do
give it a thumbs up if you did and don't
forget to subscribe also hit that Bell
button when you click the subscribe
button because subscribe doesn't really
do anything anymore so if you actually
want to find out when we put out new
videos you got to hit that Bell it's
just the way it goes and as always thank
you for watching